bueno
hola me llamo lagunés tenía 15 años y
hermosa tabasco al principio si sentía
mucho aburrimiento al estar encerrada
aquí en mi casa porque no hacía nada por
el paso del tiempo es mi escuela igual
tomó las medidas de tomar clases en
línea también si me ha afectado el no
salir ya que yo he acostumbrado mucho a
salir todos los fines de semana con mis
amigos con mi familia he aprovechado
muchísimas cosas así como en los cursos
que están dando ahorita en línea este
necesito una de repostería metía uno de
inglés y me metí uno de ballet que
normalmente acostumbramos a hacer
festivales en los teatros y ahorita se
tomó una medida de hacerlos por medio de
zoom de la plataforma azul y ha tenido
dos
méxico lo veía tan lejos y tan
superficial que al principio no se lo
tomó nada en serio hasta que vieron los
casos cómo iban aumentando poco a poco
por ejemplo aquí en tabasco los casos
están muy altos desde uno de los estados
más contagiados que hay en el en el país
cuando el gobierno indique que el
semáforo esté en verde me gustaría mucho
regresar a la escuela con incluidas
presenciales a mis clases de baile poder
viajar visitar a mi familia lo que estoy
aprendiendo durante esta pandemia al
estar en casa es obviamente a ser
tolerante a mejorar la convivencia con
mi familia aprender a estar todos juntos
en un lugar cerrado al igual cómo
mantenerme ocupada como por ejemplo a
estar cocinando a estar bailando tomar
clases de baile de diferente tipo
[Música]